plongez vous dans une piscine d'acide
pour un million d'euros
trop dangereux d'après toi et pourtant
une autre mission de l'acide a été
construit par le cinéma dans les films
un simple contact avec ce liquide dit
sous la main en quelques secondes sans
tuteur en compte mais si tout ça n'était
qu'une croyance populaire
aujourd'hui je vous propose une approche
scientifique et complète sur ce qu'est
vraiment la cee'd et promis à la fin de
la vidéo vous y penserez à deux fois
avant de refuser ce million de dollars
combien de temps pour dissoudre un corps
dans l'acide en 2018
un célèbre youtuber scientifique a eu
une idée folle tester l'action de
différents acides sur ses propres mains
bon évidemment la vidéo n'est pas resté
très longtemps sur youtube
c'est dommage parce qu'elle nous
apprenait plein de choses dans la vidéo
il peut plonger sa main une minute dans
l'acide chlorhydrique et rien quand ça
commence à piquer il la retire sans
aucun dommage apparent sur l'acide
nitrique réputé terriblement puissant il
a quand même pu tenir une douzaine de
secondes
bon après sa main est revenue un peu
fripé en plélan main avec une teinte
jaunâtre
que faire alors de ces histoires de
chimistes qui aurait perdu un doigt en
le trempant quelques secondes dans
l'acide par exemple l'acide
fluorhydrique avec des nerfs si
rapidement détruit qu'il n'aurait même
pas senti la douleur
c'est ce qu'à des banques et la chaîne
périodiques théberge tu peux
effectivement père dont on doit il faut
des soeurs avant que ça arrive et je
pense que personne ne va avoir un doigt
qui ressemble à cette cuisse de poulet
que des gueux les dégâts là il faut un
peu démystifier l'action de la civ
et pour ça entrons dans le niveau
moléculaire vous le savez en atom c'est
un noyau avec des électrons les deux
s'équilibrent on dit que l'atom est
électriquement neutre mais qu'est ce qui
se passe quand on retire ou qu'on
n'ajoute un électron passé tout casser
l'atom devient électriquement soit trop
positifs soit trop négatif on appelle ça
un oignon et le souci d'un acide c'est
ça c'est une molécule normale sur
laquelle il ya un ou plusieurs atomes
d'hydrogène déséquilibré ici il leur
manquait un électron et cet hydrogène là
s'il veut soit s'en débarrasser soit
leur équilibre et en volant un électron
ça elle le fera sur la molécule qui aura
le malheur de passer à côté d'elle par
exemple quand le faire rencontre la
cyclo adriq lyon hydrogène libéré va
piquer des électrons
r ce qui va déséquilibrer la tomme et si
de l'oxygène passe par la fair value
foncé dessus en mode je me sens si seuls
réconforte mois et pof de la rouille
c'est ça que placide elle vole des
électrons à des molécules qui du coup
change de forme ce processus en
apparence simple peut faire de gros
dégâts
plus tard dans la vidéo comment faire
ses effets impressionnants de dilution
instantanée pour l'instant garder juste
à l'esprit que ça prend du temps et ça
va être important pour répondre à notre
question est ce que la cide permet de
faire le crime parfait de faire
disparaître ses victimes dans l'histoire
on a plusieurs témoignages de criminels
qui ont essayé john hering serial killer
qui buvait leçons de ses victimes avant
de les disposer dans des bidons d'un
site you purique dans son jardin la
chimiste larissa acheteurs qui a dissous
son mari avec elle divorce et elle
endormie accus chloroforme et sans même
le tuer elle l'a enfermé dans une jarre
plein d'acide
enfin la mafia mexicaine ou sicilienne
connu pour sa loupe arabi en cas ce qui
va vraiment popularisé l'idée de
dissoudre en cours dans l'acide c'est
évidemment la série breaking bad écoute
les actions d'acide fluorhydrique pour
dissoudre les eaux
car dans les cas précédents que je viens
de citer les acides choisis n'ont pas
permis de totalement dissoudre les corps
et c'est comme ça que la police a pu
identifier les victimes et arrêter les
criminels
du coup est-ce que l'acide fluorhydrique
de breaking bad est meilleur
techniquement son ph n'est pas très bas
c'est même considéré comme un acide
faible mais il a comme propriété unique
de s'attaquer à tous les métaux les ou
le verre la céramique
c'est pour ça que dans breaking bad le
corps la baignoire et le plafond tout
finit par être dissous le truc c'est que
mythe buster attesté d'en verser sur les
différents éléments de la scène de
breaking bad
il est résultat est un peu décevant il
restera toujours du cra une sorte de
peau un peu cuivre et des autres venus
très souple mais pas totalement dissous
car oui à six attaques à tout mais pas
très rapidement et pas très efficacement
il semble donc impossible totalement
faire disparaître un corps avec de
l'acide moins que peut-être qu'il existe
une méthode en essayant de trouver un
acide interdit encore plus puissant
quelle est la cible
puissant ça c'est une des expériences de
la chaîne chemistry flic une orange qui
disparaît totalement en moins d'une
minute pareil avec les éponges les
pommes et même un pauvre iphone
sacrifiés pourquoi ça marche si bien là
alors que comme on l'a vu précédemment d
asi parfois très puissant mettent des
heures avant de dissoudre partiellement
une pattes de poulet l'idée reçue ici
c'est de croire que seule la cites tout
seul suffit dans la réalité il faut
combiner cinq autres facteurs pour
espérer avoir la cee'd le plus puissant
le potentiel de l'acide ses propriétés à
quoi on le mélange sa température et sa
concentration
premièrement commençons par le potentiel
de las il est d'abord question comment
mesurer sa puissance avec quels outils
on connaît le ph le p étant un opérateur
mathématiques pour dire - log et le h
pour hydrogène mais les gens ont préféré
donner un autre origine stories avec
potentiel hydrogène
c'est une mesure utilisée par exemple
dans les piscines le souci du ph et que
c'est une mesure qui ne fonctionne que
si on l'associé dans une solution avec
de l'eau par exemple
or tous les acides ne se dissolve pas
dans l'eau c'est pourquoi il est plus
simple d'utiliser une autre mesure la
constante d'acidité noté pk plus le pk
est petit plus la cee'd sera considéré
comme fort
ainsi l'acide sulfurique à un pk de -3
tout ce qui est en dessous est considéré
comme super acide
le plus fort des super racines non
mélangés et la cl cargo rail avec un pk
de -24 dit autrement c'est minimum un
million de fois plus fort que l'acide
sulfurique
avec ce que je viens de vous dire vous
êtes en train de penser que pour
dissoudre un corps il suffirait juste de
prendre la cible plus fort et hop mais
détrompez vous les mesures d'acidité
mesure la capacité à donner des ions on
a rien qui sert à calculer la puissance
de destruction d'un acide par exemple
l'acide car brad on vient de parler
il a beau être la cie de pur le plus
fort connu il n'est absolument pas
corrosif c'est pour ça qu'il faut aussi
prendre en compte le deuxième point les
propriétés de l'acide
vous l'aurez compris un acide a beau
être puissant c'est qui va faire des
dégâts
ce sont ces propriétés et son champ
d'action l'acide chlorhydrique va
libérer des thons chlorure l'acide
sulfurique des ions sulfates et l'acide
nitrique des ions nitrates chacun de ces
ions va avoir des actions
préférentielles sur certains types de
molécules
le meilleur exemple de ses préférences
et l'acide fluorhydrique c'est simple il
peut carrément dissoudre du verre si
cette magie possible c'est parce que cet
acide lillers des ions fluor f moi qui
sont très violents et surtout aime
beaucoup les ions métalliques il les
aime tellement qu'ils vont se jeter sur
eux ils s'y fixe est très fort ça a
l'air tout mignon comme ça mais en
réalité ça a des conséquences
catastrophiques
le calcium de vos os par exemple basse
et du métal lésions fiore vont non
seulement les déplacés mais surtout les
rendent soluble dans l'eau et de l'eau
vous en avez énormément dans votre corps
troisièmement les mélanges
normalement vous devez avoir tiqué quand
j'ai dit que le super à six le plus fort
était la seule quart borhane ben c'est
faux parce que dans la classification
deux acides arrive plus haut que lui
l'acide magique et l'acide fluoro anti
monique la particularité de ces acides
c'est que ce sont en réalité des
mélanges le super acide furent anti
money par exemple est un mélange de
penthaz fluorure d'antimoine et de
fluorure d'hydrogène
le tout donne un acide avec un p cadeau
- moins 30 soit 2 milliards de fois plus
fort que l'acide sulfurique tellement
fort que pour reproduire l'expérience de
breaking bad avec lui il faudrait
dissoudre le corps dans une poêle plutôt
qu'une baignoire car le téflon est le
seul matériau que cette assise ne peut
pas dissoudre pour illustrer
l'importance des mélanges je dois
absolument vous parler des deux plus
célèbres
d'abord lors égale un mélange de l'acide
chlorhydrique et de l'acide nitrique
sont capables dissoudre l'or et le
platine aucun acide pure n'est capable
de faire ça le deuxième mélange célèbre
vous l'avez peut-être vu dans une vidéo
de docteur noces ban c'est le mélange
piranhas acide sulfurique plus haut à
oxygéner son action et terrifiante
l'oxygéner étant un excellent en
occident le mélanger à à l'acide
sulfurique concentré va booster ses
capacités corrosif
ce dernier ne l'étant naturellement pas
assez pour dissoudre quelque chose à
cette vitesse quatrièmement la
température de l'acide
c'est un facteur sous-estimé mais qui
peut centuple et l'efficacité d'un acide
une goutte d'acide sulfurique froid son
autre main et vous mettez un peu de
temps à ressentir la douleur
de l'acide sulfurique brûlant et la
réaction sera immédiate c'est comme pour
compte et si ces choses ça dit lui plus
vite pour le coup on a un exemple assez
horrifique au parc yellowstone dabbachi
à une activité volcanique et donc des
bassins d'acide sulfurique et ça arrive
que des touristes qui veulent un peu
trop faire les malins genre par exemple
montrer à leurs stocks qui sont capables
de toucher cette eau glisse sur la roche
et tombe dans ses cuves d'acide
sulfurique a plus de 100 degrés c'est ce
qui s'est passé pour colin nathaniel
scott dont on a retrouvé de lui
seulement ses tongs
cinquièmement la concentration de
l'acier bah oui - ces mélanges et plus
et pure sauf que quand vous achetez un à
six est rarement du 100% c'est comme
l'eau de javel ou tu achètes 97 % d'eau
pour 3% de javel le fait de n'être pas
concentré à 100% ne veut pas dire que
l'acide est moins fort bien au contraire
ajoutez de l'eau peut démarrer les
réactions et les mélanges avec d'autres
substances peuvent décupler le pouvoir
corrosif une bonne raison de ne pas
utiliser un acide 100% pur c'est aussi
une question de stockage l'acide
sulfurique par exemple c'est très dur à
trouver pur car très instable
naturellement le produit tend à se
stabiliser autour des 98 % en relâchant
une partie de son prix oxydes de soufre
l'attend vous savez pourquoi certains
youtuber font instantanément disparaître
les cuisses de poulet tandis que
d'autres mettent des jours entiers il
faut que chaque paramètre qu'on a vues
soit prise en compte la cible tout seul
ne suffit pas vous possédez des litres
d'acide dans votre corps c'est étonnant
qu'on ait eu aussi peur de l'acide
alors que c'est un élément essentiel à
la fois en nous et dans notre
alimentation
le vinaigre le citron le coca le lsd ou
même la vitamine c
ce sont des acides et pathé acide nous
non plus vendre dans l'échelle du punch
sont pas tout en bas le vinaigre peut
dissoudre la coquille d'un oeuf et
l'acide du citron dissous dans la roue
du métal même vous tuer si vous en buvez
trop par curiosité j'ai cherché sur
internet des mecs qui avaient bu d
incident puissant par erreur vous savoir
quel goût ça avait et j'ai découvert
qu'il y avait des mecs qu'il faisait
mais pas par erreur un port tester genre
boire de l'acide sulfurique très diluées
dans l'eau
je préviens apparemment ça injuste un
goût acide comme du citron mais
n'essayez pas c'est un coup à mourir en
plus boire ce genre de trucs
vous l'avez testé sans le savoir par
exemple si vous avez mangé du poisson
pas frais trop de chocolat ou cinq
scooters de tequila à la suite
si c'est le cas vous avez peut-être
remarqué que votre vous
un goût acide est ce normal puisque
c'est de la file chlorhydrique vont
vomissez un décapant pour toilettes
je rigole pas en votre estomac est
remplie d'un liquide dont les
autocollants indique danger ça va aussi
dire que vous avez en vous des cellules
qui produisent et crash de l'acide et ça
c'est stylé mais comment fait notre
corps pour ne pas fondre deux raisons
d'abord une grosse dilution l'acide
gastrique c'est plein de choses avec un
ph qui s'autorégule à la fin de la
digestion ce qui ressort c'est quasiment
plus acide et encore heureux parce que
sinon ça je t'offre et le cube ensuite
et c'est la protection principal de
votre corps votre estomac est tapissé
d'un épais mucus protecteur sauf que
certaines bactéries pour fuir la cee'd
vous creuser des tunnels dans ce mucus
ce qui fait que la cide peut
s'engouffrer pour les veaux paroisse et
provoquer des ulcères tokoin cet
incident reste un peu dangereux quand
même comment réagir face à l'acide
angleterre 23 septembre 2015 le docteur
nick white aperçoit au loin un homme
couvert debout criant l'aide dans sa rue
cet homme c'était marc baume dogan est
ce qu'il avait sur lui c'était pas de la
boue mais sa peau en train de fondre la
raison de cette scène d'horreur une
attaque orchestrée par son ex petit ami
ne supportant pas d'être quittée la
veille elle avait commandé un bidon
d'acide sulfurique sur amazon était allé
se renseigner sur internet pour
connaître la meilleure méthode pour
réussir son attaque
elle a pris perpétuité en prison et marc
a tellement souffert pendant des mois
qu'il finit par demander l'euthanasie
qu'au début des années 2010 ces attaques
était devenu une mode à londres
au point d'avoir le taux de crimes à
l'acide le plus haut du monde en 2017
il y avait plus de deux attaques par
jour il y avait des mecs qui balançait
ça au hasard dans des boîtes de nuit
ce n'est pas la première fois que cela
se passe dans l'histoire en france au
19ème siècle il y avait déjà eu le
mouvement des beats rieuse des femmes
qui défigurent leurs maris volages et
qui surtout n'était pas condamné eu que
la loi considère et ça au même niveau
qu'une bagarre heureusement ça a changé
depuis les sanctions sont devenus très
lourde mais imaginons quelque chose de
malheureux pendant vos vacances à
londres cet événement tragique vous
arrive
si la cie d'effroi vous avez une petite
minute avant qu'il y ait des dégâts si
les shows vous avez quelques secondes
il faudra 1 c'est avec de l'eau beaucoup
d'eau l'avait aussi longtemps que les
secours arrivent
la douleur était infernal insurmontable
mais surtout ne paniquez pas appelé les
secours ne m'étais aucune crème
n'essayez pas de neutraliser la cee'd
avec du bicarbonate et surtout ne
touchez pas avec vos mains ça
contaminerait la clé vous n'allez pas
forcément être défiguré mais il faut
agir vite
si je vous parle de ces trucs horribles
c'est que je voulais pas qu'on nous
accuse de donner le mauvais exemple de
sous-estimer les dangers de ces
substances
oui il ya des idées reçues mais non la
sinne n'est pas un jouet ce qui nous
amène à pouvoir répondre à notre
question du début est ce que pour 1
million d'euros soit dans une piscine
d'acide prend les amis aussi c'est pas
un hyper acide si la température est
froide si c'est bien diluée et si tu
peux porter des lunettes de plongée
si par contre c'est un incident très
fort et que la température est chaude
bombe à éviter cette aventure au coeur
des acides touche déjà à sa fin
on remercie notre ami sky d'avoir bossé
sur ce sujet on s'est entouré de
plusieurs spécialistes avec musicor un
super chimiste que je vous conseille de
suivre sur twitter et bulgares med1
youtuber spécialisés en médecine
à suivre aussi remercié les monteurs qui
font toujours un excellent travail
n'hésitez pas à les suivre sur twitter
c'était matar est née oxis ciao
ouais